Jay Sekulow is one of the president's
personal attorneys he joins us from
Washington good morning Jay I want to
start with the special counsel found no
connection between the Trump campaign
and the Russian interference activities
but on the question of obstruction he
chose very specific language and I want
to get your your thoughts about that he
said that while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him he
didn't have to use that language and the
Attorney General didn't have to reprint
it what do you make of that specific
language well I think what it says and
this is if you understand the internal
workings of the Department of Justice
doesn't make sense so he issued a series
of facts and then looked at the law and
said it raised difficult questions of
law in fact well you don't bring a
charge on difficult law and facts unless
you get approval that that theory of law
would be correct so what he did which
was appropriate under the Department of
Justice guidelines he went to the Office
of Legal Counsel because remember bob
was part of the department justice
unlike an Independent Counsel and he
went to the Department of Justice for
the Office of Legal Counsel and the
Deputy Attorney General and they
reviewed these difficult questions of
law in facts as they were described by
the special counsel and made the
conclusion that they were was not an
obstruction of justice there was no
underlying crime being obstructed and
there was not sufficient evidence for an
obstruction claimed and that's why at
the end of the letter the Attorney
General says that in consultation with
the Office of Legal Counsel the
Department of Justice and the Deputy
Attorney General the United States that
conclusion was reached
meaning that the Attorney General's and
the Department of Justice position is
there was no collusion and thus no
obstruction right that's the that's the
position the Attorney General took but
but this specific language and the
reason as important as the president's
claimed exoneration the special counsel
could have done everything you've
suggested but not used that specific
language and so that's what's what's
seems puzzling here on the one hand the
president claims that he was exonerated
the special counsel accepting everything
you've just said nevertheless chose to
use very specific words which is yep
that he does not exonerate him well no
but he also said that the equation of a
violation of criminal law which is a
variant
Horton's statement here so what did the
special counsel say they could not
conclude there was a legal uh violation
in other words a case that they would
have moved forward on so they put it up
to the Department of Justice because
that's the reporting authority for the
special counsel of the United States
that's how it works when you appoint a
special counsel under DOJ guidelines and
regulations that's how this moves
forward and they made the determination
in other words Bob Muller wanted the
Department of Justice to make the
determination because that becomes a
question of policy for the Department of
Justice of what does and does not
constitute an obstruction of justice and
here the Department of Justice and
consultation with the Office of Legal
Counsel again the Deputy Attorney
General and the Attorney General made
the conclusion Democrats are calling for
the release of the full report J so that
the public can weigh in and draw their
own conclusions is the Trump
administration pushing for that as well
well what the administration is said
obviously I'm speaking here as a private
lawyer is that they they want as much
transparency as the Attorney General
feels like under the regulations he can
provide obviously there's and the
Attorney General said this there's
what's called 60 material when we get
too technical that's Grand Jury material
there may be national security
information in there that cannot be
disclosed but I think the Attorney
General is going to disclose as much as
he can without compromising national
security and grand jury material if it's
disclosed what happens there that's a
crime actually so there will have to be
that's why I think that part of the
review takes a little bit longer but
look this is a decision the Attorney
General makes under the regulations and
he'll make it I trust general Barr to do
the right thing well there are questions
about the attorney general by the way
the Attorney General William bar and rod
Rosen son because they are Trump
appointees that they're not really
impartial are those concerns legit on
the part of the Democrats no they're not
because this was when you look at the
office of legal counsel and the Attorney
General and the dag and the dag rod
Rhodes ensigns been in this case since
the very beginning he appointed Robert
Mahler and Bob Muller did not make a
determination of any kind of criminality
on either count on the collusion which
would by the way was the basis upon
which this whole investigation started
and you had members of the United States
Congress said there was clear evidence
of collusion between the Trump campaign
and the Russian government and Russian
operatives and that was completely
dismissed by the special counsel
then when they had what they call the
difficult questions of law in fact they
followed the policy and went to the
Department of Justice who made that
determination Jay the president called
the Moller investigation an illegal
investigation that failed what was
illegal about it well look how it
started I mean the investigation starts
based on the Christopher Steele dossier
which James Comey himself called
salacious and unverified that was the
basis upon which this whole process
started and it was started because of
alleged Russian collusion it was a
counterintelligence it wasn't it started
after the firing of mr. Comey no it
would be this the the operation
crossfire hurricane started a year
before that but Jamie Papadopoulos based
on the populist material not because of
the steel dossier that was not the
initiating that was not the initiating
event it was the Papadopoulos comments
actually it's not correct so what what
is correct is the dossier with Bruce
Norris testified to this was the
motivating factor to start this inquiry
start and remembers a
counterintelligence investigation and
the end result after two years and again
thousands of documents hundreds of
witnesses 2,800 subpoenas what what did
you find on Russian collusion nothing
why because there was none which was the
position we advocated from the outset
does the president have a message for
Bob Muller this morning well I believe
that look I would leave that to the
president I will say here's my message
to Bob Muller I'm glad the investigation
has been concluded I'm glad that we can
move forward now as a country there's a
lot of good things that can happen in
Congress I mean I'm a big advocate of
comprehensive immigration reform for
instance and I think you know the idea
that there's gonna be these ongoing
congressional oversight hearings on
something that's been delved into and
just look at the numbers 2,800 subpoenas
500 search warrants 230 orders of
communication records 50 orders
authorizing pen registers 13 requests to
foreign governments and over 500
witnesses for the Congress to go over
all that again to me is a waste of money
it's political let's get on with the
people's business all right that's a job
like the send message received
Jay Sekulow thanks so much for being
with us thanks for having me